so viel zu lesen so wenig zeit drei der
bekanntesten us amerikanischen
autoren haben wir ein bisschen unter die
lupe genommen und ihr erfahrt ob ihr sie
lesen ist oder nicht
[Musik]
wir sind ja nicht zuletzt dafür da euch
das leben schöner und einfacher zu
machen und in diesem bestreben haben wir
die wichtigen titel dieses herbst
winters studiert damit ihr es nicht oder
nur wenn ihr wollt also nicola stephen
king will ich sagen was soll ich das
lesen also unter dem aspekt der
literatur ja wenn du dafür kein großes
sensorium hast kann ich sie nicht ans
herz legen es geht um einen
auftragskiller der einen anderen
auftragskiller ermorden soll und um das
zu tun lässt er sich in einem kleinen
städtchen in den usa nieder und gibt
sich als schriftsteller aus und dann
bringt er diesen auftragskiller oben
stellt fest dass er von seinem
auftraggeber über den tisch gezogen
wurde und es beginnt ein rachefeldzug
das ist jetzt mal so der erste plot das
sind natürlich übersehen
kann nicht gerade sagen dass mich das
jetzt animiertes zu lesen du eine
nacherzählung liefert die ungefähr so
dick ist wie das buch untersagt es ist
nur der erste stern das wird sehr viel
aber das gute ist steven kind kann
wirklich schreiben es geht um rache es
geht um schuld aber zwischen den zeilen
geht es eben auch um lebenslügen und um
eine unglückliche kindheit das ist ganz
viel drin verpackt was wirklich über den
reinen zu mit hinausgeht und gab es auch
irgendetwas was dir nicht so gut
gefallen hat naja dieses übliche
argument die frauen die in dem buch
vorkommen obwohl der stephen king ein
erklärter feminist ist denen muss
geholfen werden wie viele von fünf
sternen gibst du stephen king ja drei
von fünf und du verpasst den neuen
johnson frentzen gelesen so dick
dafür einen skeptischen roth wurde
dieser stimme aber muss man gelesen
haben ja ich kann ganz viel zu dem buch
sagen aber ich fasse mich cool es geht
um die familie hildebrandt die alle
sozusagen versuchen ein guter mensch zu
sagen alle figuren sind so angelegt dass
ist einmal die wenn du so willst
puritanische wohlerzogen zivilisierte
seite gibt und dann gibt es auch noch
die etwas animalische bedürftige seite
und alle figuren befragen sich permanent
selbst indem es tun oder nicht tun
daraufhin ist das gut und richtig was
ich jetzt mache sind auch meine
motivation gut und richtig aber es ist
sehr anstrengend da fragst du dich auch
die ganze zeit ob du dich richtig oder
falsch verhält mit deiner die eigenen
zielsicherheit berührst du genau wie ich
finde den kritischen punkt in diesem
buch ich finde ich auch dass das ein
lesenswertes buch es aber mir ist das
auch zu durchexerziert also wie viele
sterne würdest du jetzt im fenster geben
ich fühle mich heute irgendwie großzügig
und gebe ihm vier von fünf nicola
richard powers erstaunen würde mich das
erstaunlich ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
das ein buch ist für dich ganz ehrlich
es ist sehr komplex was ja
[Gelächter]
nein es geht auf der einen seite um die
wissenschaft der vater des sohnes ist
ein astrobiologe und es geht um
neurowissenschaften und neuro
enhancement denn die mutter ist ein jahr
zuvor verstorbenen die umweltschützerin
war und man versucht jetzt ein über
künstliche intelligenz das gehirn des
jungen neu zu triggern und zwar mit den
gefühlen der mutter der junge verändert
sich aber wie man sich schon denken kann
das ganze geht nicht so gut aus wie im
märchen es klingt sehr dicht es ist klar
die es ist wahnsinnig viel drin für
dieses jahr wenig das habe ich gerade
sorgen bedeutet das dass es auch eine
sehr intensive lektüre ist dass mich so
ein bisschen irritiert hat ist auch so
eine leicht moralische haltung der
umwelt gegenüber weil natürlich das ist
eine wichtige botschaft des buches wir
keine zeit mehr haben und wir unbedingt
den verfall unserer erde aufhalten
müssen und wenn wir das nicht sofort tun
dann hat ebenso ein zehnjähriger junge
wie dieser robin im buch keine zukunft
und das ist das kann er sehr
nachdrücklich
veranschaulichen aber manchmal ist es
mir auch wahnsinnig moralisch wie viele
von fünf stören drei von fünf also 1 1
ein jahr in willich eingangs sagte
[Musik]